mark Meadows just walking out joining us
congressman thanks for being here it's
great give us an inside scoop what kind
of behind the scenes of this meeting you
know obviously it was a very long
meeting where the president was talking
about not only the agenda on immigration
that's certainly what we've accomplished
what we need to do from here but it's
all about getting it done he really
wants us to make sure that we put up 218
votes on the House floor this week he
said he's behind us a thousand percent
obviously wants to deal with this
separation issue with children at the
border but both bills actually do that
the compromise bill or the leadership
bill is certainly the one that seems to
have the the most the highest
probability of getting a 218 uh-huh the
president just walked by the microphone
didn't stop the number of Democrats
there chanting about getting families
together did President say you know that
he knows that he can he can do a change
himself or how did he play it with the
legislation yeah I knew that he had
secretary Neilson there and obviously
she was there in the room and talking
about the fact that we've we've got to
find a real solution to this but this is
more a legislative solution this is
something that we've been dealing with a
long time when when you look at a
protection of children that's why this
decree came down originally but they
believe that it's it's best that we get
a legislative solution I think there's
some narrow bills that both in the House
and the Senate that will address this
issue but I'm hearing Chuck Schumer is
not supportive of any any legislative
effort we just reported that and that's
what he said today to reporters is that
there's not a Republican legislative
solution that Democrats will sign on to
and your reaction to that well my
reaction if that is read the bills I
mean I know we've introduced a bill the
senator ted cruz's introduced a bill but
is he saying that there's no legislative
solution and when you look at that brett
i think that the american people want us
to solve it i've been getting calls all
day long but at the same time they want
to
come together Democrats and Republicans
I think a number of us are giving them
the opportunity to do that I want to
listen and just see if the president
says anything is he's with the House
Majority Leader McCarthy
[Music]
kind of reiterating their count already
said going in the laws have been broken
for decades and you had a great meeting
he did he talked a lot about immigration
or was it a mix a minute it was a real
mix I think he started with immigration
he came back to immigration both in the
middle and at the end but we talked
about regulation we talked about
actually the Association health plans
that bring down premiums for health care
that he's he's signing in with the
Secretary of Labor and is there an
urgency here or is this an issue that
both sides are kind of playing politics
with yeah I can tell you that that our
side is not playing politics with it I
had my staff working over the weekend to
come up with a legislative fix 77 pages
that really we worked around the clock
to get introduced today and we did that
at noon and so it's not about politics
it's about getting the job done right
unfortunately it has been a political
football back and forth and when you're
dealing with people's lives you got to
make sure that you get it done right
hopefully we will and I believe we will
this week and we're Republicans in that
meeting saying we need to either do a
narrow bill or president you have to
change this dynamic yeah I think right
now the the focus was on the the to more
comprehensive bills there was not a lot
of discussion about a narrow bill
although the the separation issue did
come up a couple of times and you know
the president was very compassionate
about it talked about his daughter
bringing that up Ivanka and and so when
you look at that it's not lost on him
that we've got to fix this but at the
same time we've got this full week I
think the the pressure is on us from the
American people to get it done this week
I believe we will Carson we appreciate
you stopping by you can understand side
scoop